[Musik]
hallo zu sagen wir machen heute eine
leckere brownie kombination nämlich
cheesecake brownies und mein gott chef
die gestern gemacht weil gestern meine
schwester zu besuch kam
und die waren hin und weg jeder hat
erstmal zu weiß stücke gegessen und dann
habe ich den rest auch noch mit geben
müssen weil die gesagt haben
hör mal und macht jeden tag wie es ist
nicht ganz so schlimm mit geben deshalb
habe ich jetzt auch nichts mehr da aber
ich hab gedacht direkt am nächsten tag
des wassers ab film weil ihr auf
instagram auch gesehen habt ok mega
lecker muss uns unbedingt zeigen daher
kommt mal rüber zum herd wir fangen
jetzt an mit dem braun itag und geld
kommt die cheesecake füllung für den
braun habe ich hier ein wasserbad dann
nehmt ihr euch einen topf für tier mit
etwas wasser
das wasser sollte aber hier die die
hitze feste hitzebeständige schüssel
nicht berühren so das weil ich es noch
einmal aufkochen lassen und da gebe ich
dann butter twitter kuvertüre und zucker
rhein und die ganz genauen mengenangaben
die stehen unten in der video
beschreibung
[Musik]
wichtiger schritt damit wir keine ruhe
bekommen wir müssen jetzt die kuvertüre
butter masse 15 minuten lang einfach nur
stehen dass man mit ein bisschen
unterkühlt und tut mir eingefallen auch
wenn es leute unter euch gibt kein
twitter fan sind nehmt bitte trotzdem
tat bitter weil das ist einfach vom
geschmack da nicht so pappig süß sondern
angenehm süß und schokoladig so als
nächstes gebe ich da ganz ganz wichtig
vanille extrakt rein einfach für den
geschmack und auch sehr wichtig eine
großzügige prise salz die hebt noch mal
den süßen geschmack
[Musik]
danach die eier zügig mit dem
schneebesen unterrühren und anschließend
kommen die trockenen zutaten dazu dann
nämlich mail und bacau ganz wichtig
nicht den trinker persönlich den süßen
cacau nehmen sondern den starken töten
bacau und jetzt einfach mit dem
schneebesen in der mitte in kreisenden
bewegungen schön einarbeiten und ihr
werdet merken es sieht schon viel aus
die trockene massereich mal aber es ist
einfach perfekt am ende so muss das 250
alles gut verbunden und das ist schon
sehr zäh und da gehört auch kein
backpulver 1 regel nummer eins bei
brownies
[Musik]
somit ist der braune teig fertig der
kommt kurz an die seite und wir machen
jetzt die queen kiesfüllung dafür
benötigen wir doppel ram frischkäse
quark funktioniert hier nicht so gut
weil pakistan so säuerlich und
vertrauten eben einfach doppelt ran
frischkäse auch nicht die fettarme
variante oder so
es gebe ich jetzt immer eine schüssel
dazu kommt ein 1 für die bindung zucker
natürlich und vanille extrakt und ich
gibt ja noch einen spritzer zitronensaft
dazu
[Musik]
somit ist die kiesfüllung auch fertig
und jetzt habe ich mir meinen ba kam auf
25 x 17 cm eingestellt ein backblech mit
backpapier belegt und jetzt gebe ich
hier ungefähr oder ich würde sagen ein
bisschen mehr als die hälfte vom brownie
teig in mein programm streichen das
glatt dann kommt die komplette cream
cheese füllung drauf und dann geben wir
den rest der des promi teigs noch mal
oben drauf damit wir das quasi
umschließen
[Musik]
und die jetzt geben wir das in den
backofen ganz ganz wichtig vorheizen auf
170 grad ober und unterhitze und ich
lasse es für 36 minuten drin ist es
nämlich richtig schön partie genauso wie
es sein muss und danach müssen was
vollständig abkühlen lassen und dann
probiert wir
[Musik]
doch ich glaube es ist noch lauwarm
morgens rover
ich mache das lauwarme kommt geführt
dass man sich für tätige nötig wenn du
machen weil sie das macht mich einfach
mal glücklich gerade das ist ein
geschmack
das ist mein herz höher springen ich
glaube so im laden wird das müsste 34
europas wenn ja auch gute zutaten und
klicken so was sie schon bleiben ich
weiß nicht ich bin mir kommt immer neue
standard törtchen wissen müssen echt ein
café aufmachen mit den top ten meiner
ganzen rezept wrestling ist man denkt
man denkt halt boah ich essen stück und
dann bin ich einfach platt ist relativ
mächtig aber nicht so dass man es
umkippt und auch nicht zu süß
aber es liegt an der zeit peter
kuvertüre und wenn sie zwischen schicht
aus cream cheese war
leute macht unbedingt nach wäre das die
namen sorry keine ahnung selber schuld
geschmückt
der 1
jetzt ganz viel spaß zum nachbacken ja
bitte
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten video
und nächsten mal dann auch wieder mit
dir zusammen mit dem test misst dann in
libyen
[Musik]